Joe Giudice celebrates his final days of  freedom  the reality star starts his 41 month  prison sentence on Wednesday I just want  to get out you know as quickly as I can  and do whatever I can you know to get  out of there  sore Styles et his family hosted an  intimate goodbye party on Monday in New  Jersey Teresa and Joe were surrounded by  75 of their closest family and friends  source adds that the night was upbeat  and positive for the most part quote  there were tears laughter joking a lot  of hugs you can only imagine the things  turned emotional when the evening came  to a close quote people were crying when  they were saying goodbye to him Teresa  plans to visit her husband at least once  a week but the Real Housewives star told  ET earlier this month that the second  period of separation is weighing heavily  on them and their four young daughters